yeah i don't want to get near that heat
and alienate anybody out there and
that's why judy and zaynab are here
ladies and gentlemen please welcome judy
gold and
zainab johnson
[Applause]
hi i love you both so much i'm so happy
we get to do this
this is so fun all right you're gonna
give us your takes on these news topics
and the first one
is uh this week's miss manners in the
washington post
answered a letter from a person upset
that their friend never
likes their social media posts and now
they're thinking of not
liking their friend's post back warm
topic
zaynab what do you think do you have to
like your friends post or not
absolutely like your friend's post we
have to choose our battles in life and
social media should never be one of them
it doesn't matter if the picture is bad
you don't like it like it heart it
love it it's your friend right it's it
takes
it's no sweat to do something like that
yeah i can see that well judy what about
you oh please okay
you can't you cannot
first of all half of my friend's posts
are full of crapola
like you cannot live up to the life that
you present on social media
they act like their perfect marriage and
everything's fantastic
and meanwhile they're all calling me
like i can't take it anymore i gotta get
out of this relationship
so i can't i don't know i can't lie i
feel like friendship without honesty is
not friendship so oh my god judy i love
you and that is exactly why we look to
you for these things
okay next step new study from boise
state university
finds that a man who holds a cat in his
dating profile
is like perceived less dateable for
women even though generally pet owners
are seen as
more data ball warm topics zaynab
cats no go for dating no
to the catman no no no judy no to the
catman first of all
if he has a cat he's dating the cat
cats are territorial they scratched up
no i want to be the only one pissing in
the house
all right i by the way i love a good
hiss judy thoughts
okay so i would this is what i think
all right i'm a lesbian so i know a lot
about felines okay
i am thinking
as if i it shows that the guy likes to
stay at home
and cuddle he's fine with cleaning cat
litter which means he'll change the
diapers
okay and he's secure enough that he
doesn't have to go outside with his big
man
dog so i think it says that he's
sensitive and uh and sort of a homebody
and i don't know i think it's a good
thing
i have to say too like when you get
older
you start ticking things off the list
that you were you know picky about
before
you're like are you nice and i don't
care if you have cats
so anyway last topic the latest new
yorker reported on an artist who takes
photos of strangers text messages while
they're not looking
it's a little voyeuristic window into
their private lives judy is it okay to
be a cell phone snooper
or not no i'm not into that
like i have so much drama in my own life
that i don't want i can't even look at
my own texts
i don't want to look at other people's
texts you know and i think
well unless it's like a casting director
or your ex
don't look at other people's texts
zaynab thoughts
um you know honestly drew i thought that
we were supposed to be maintaining six
feet distance so i don't know how you
would see someone's text
anyway they now as i say
to frankie all the time which is a quote
from a cartoon
a touche pussycat absolutely
you